it'll be colby howard making his fifth
start of the season coming out for rough
adding last week allard is owen two with
a 782 era it'll be his fifth start of
the year marcus sammy in the first
batter of the ball game he's had back to
back three hit games and he works
quickly boy here comes a one-two and
simeon strikes out swinging one away oh
that was a good change up
and that'll bring up piscotty stephen
batting at 260. bob melvin had to
do some alterations on his lineup
tonight because matt chapman was the
late scratch
2-2
and he takes strike three called in a
perfect top of the first veteran
right-hander mike fires out of hollywood
florida will pitch for the oakland ac's
3-1 with a 581 earned run average shinsu
will lead it off choose santana and
trevino against the ace right-hander
veteran right-hander with the full count
pitch to shinsuchu
he rocks turns and it's on the way and
that swung on and missed on a fastball
up and away in shoe case and the rangers
have a two out rally
first and second two outs for todd
frazier in a scoreless ball game
so two on two out here's the pitch and
frazier it's a high pop up on the
infield it's simeon coming in marcus is
calling for it into the dirties there
and he makes the catch fires works out
of it the rangers leave runners at first
and second they're two outs and that'll
bring joey gallow to the plate
joey walked against fires back in the
first max kepler is the only batter
who's faced the shift in a higher
percentage of his plate appearances than
joey
runners going on a double steal the
throw goes into center field coming in
from third is two
santana will go to third base
and the rangers steal a run from oakland
in the third inning the rangers are on
the board on a throwing error from the
catcher sean murphy and they take a
one-nothing lead
one-nothing texas runner third
and the pitch is skied behind second
base
that'd be a chance for barretto and the
shift makes the cast standing is over
but
the rangers literally steal a run
and thanks in part to an a's error and
we go to the fourth one nothing texas
so here's derek dietrich
dieter grounded out to second back in
the second
rangers leading one-nothing bottom of
the fourth one away
dietrich
says dietrich stuck his elbow out he may
have
fires back with a 2-2 and it's a curved
chased and missed down in the zone and
out of the zone and dietrich is down on
strikes now kinder philippa stands in
he struck out his first time up
one two
chases went down and away a change up
and down goes kinder philippa and the
rangers so fires strands the double at
second we're through four
one three and one for the rangers oh oh
and one for the oaklands murphy fly to
center his first time
and this one
out toward right field coming on fort
gallo into a dive and he makes the case
what a catch nice play by joey gallo to
take a hit away
kobe allard raises his glove up in
salute of his right fielder who has just
preserved the no hitter for him so two
out olson's at first one-nothing rangers
and here's barretto
allard's slowing down the pace a bit now
he's a fast worker 2-2 delivery
swing and a miss he's struck him out
fourth strikeout for allard the a's are
hitless through five and it's female
machine leading off for the a's against
colby allard
machine with a hard ground ball kinder
philip is there
one away in the sixth inning
so two on one out here's piscotty good
opportunity for the a's
piscotty hits a shot left field that's a
base hit
marcus simeon digging around home
digging around third two home and he's
gonna score easily and this game is tied
to scotty comes through again
and with three walks and a single the
athletics have tied this game at one
and a chance for a big inning now as
matt olson will check in against
right-hander
luis garcia
lariana can really get down the line
over at third he's taking his lead in
the o2 pitch in the dirt it gets away
from trevino and the ace take the lead
scoring is laureano piscotti goes to
third and canna goes to second on the
wild pitch
so these get a gift and they take a 2-1
lead
there's a swing and a miss strike three
olson strikes out for the second out of
the inning and shawn murphy will be
coming up
0-2 and here it comes
swung on and the fly ball hit the center
field tavares gliding back has it
measured makes the catch over the
shoulder in front of the track to close
out the inning but the a's turn the game
around two runs on one hit
basic could extend the a's lead here
with loriano standing in he is fly to
right hit one deep to center that was
caught by tavares and then walked
the 2-2
strike three count over the inside
corner rodriguez with a little
hesitation lead kick maybe to throw off
the timing he gets the strikeout to work
around his own air so here's robbie
grossman
he has one career grand slam
grossman waits and now the 01 pitch to
robbie is high and tight hit him and he
got nailed by a fastball in 98 and the
east take a 3-1 lead the hard way and
that'll bring up
machine whose walk bounced out and
reached on an error
the pitch is on the way
swing in the miss he struck him out on a
slider
and goody strikes out three with the
bases loaded to keep the rangers in the
blogging
right now they're leading 3-1
and canna checks in
0-1 there's a hot shot but right at
connor felefa in the three-man shift on
the left guns to first for the out and
two way and that'll bring up solac
and now here's the pitch to solac it's
on the way swung on dribbled toward
third charging chapman tough play bare
hand pickup throw on a hop dug out by
olson what a way to end the game a
scintillating play by matt chapman and
then matt olson digs the ball out of the
dirt